pour prendre le dessus sur les russes
les ukrainiens compte sur l'aide
extérieure est des européens et des
américains ces derniers leur ont livré
une pluie de missiles guidés les fameux
imart mais il faut former les
combattants d'ukrainiens à ces nouvelles
armes ça a été dans le jeu d'une réunion
aujourd'hui des ministres européens de
la défense que vous avez suivi bonjour
caroline de camaret comment former les
soldats ukrainiens sans passer pour les
belligérants c'est toute la difficulté
voilà c'est ça c'est à dire c'est
d'ailleurs aussi l'objet ça a été
l'objet du sommet informel de ce matin à
prague des ministres de la défense
informel ça veut dire en général sans
résultat bon là en l'occurrence ça veut
plutôt dire qu'ils ont obtenu à
l'unanimité de queue on développe cette
idée d'une mission européenne de
formation vous l'avez dit les soldats et
craignent un son plutôt former sur du
matériel russe et ils reçoivent de plus
en plus d'armes des européens et des
américains sur lesquels ils doivent être
formés alors pour le chef de la
diplomatie européenne josep borrell on
voulait une déclaration politique
générale en disant que nous étions tous
d'accord nous sommes tous d'accord mais
on voit bien que la mission européenne
elle n'est pas encore tout à fait lancée
à l'est son idée et ébaucher les y avait
des réticences quand même du côté du
luxembourg par exemple on disait est ce
que cela ne va pas être fait plus
rapidement ou mieux en bilatéral comme
cet effet jusqu'à présent entre les pays
qui vendent des armes et ceux qui les
reçoivent en l'occurrence l'ukraine
d'autres disaient comme comme les
autrichiens la question a clarifié c'est
ce qu'on est capables nous est ce qu'on
sait mettre en place une force de
formations européennes et puis on avait
des plus favorables au projet comme les
slovaques par exemple qui ont proposé
qu'il soit que cette force soit
installée chez eux ou les néerlandais
qui expliqué qu'ils ont formées déjà des
ukrainiens au royaume-uni alors pourquoi
pas justement sur sol européen en tant
que tel ce qui est vrai que c'est que
les européens ont véritablement lâché
les cordons de la bourse depuis le début
de la guerre en ukraine avec une
facilité pour la paix c'est à dire à un
endroit où on pioche pour leur acheter
des armes doté de 5 7 milliards d'euros
maintenant et 500 millions d'euros tous
les deux ans pour des achats européen en
commun donc on est dans une course de
vie test sur une défense qui doit
rattraper en effet une guerre qui est
difficile à remporter pour les et
craignent un sérieux